[Music]
welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is gonna be my Mandalorian episode 6
video probably the most cameo heavy
episode so far so we'll break it down if
you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe I'll be doing Easter Egg
videos for all the episodes because they
finally have baby Yoda merch we'll do a
giveaway for that all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave your
favorite moment from the episode on the
video careful for spoilers if you have
not seen the episode yet will do top 10
WTF and Easter eggs as we go along
starting with number 10 the title of the
episode the prisoner so it's mostly
meant to be a heist episode heist gone
wrong which is the trope of the heist
movie genre but it also kind of turned
into a horror movie halfway through
really reminiscent ooh that badass
ending scene from rogue one with darth
vader where everything goes red and he
just ignites his a lightsaber it just
cuts through all them the mando taking
down all the other bounty hunters in the
crew but number 9 welcome back partner
in crime with a ton of cameos like I
said most cameo heavy episodes so far
the black market space station that they
arrive at at the beginning of the
episode looks just like one of the Ralph
McQuarrie concept art drawings from the
original trilogy there's an r2 unit in
the background if there's all kinds of
ships being repaired all over the place
this is just meant to give you a sense
for the scale and what they can do with
their special effects they probably
spent way more money on this episode not
only because they had way more
characters but because it was so special
effects heavy seriously you couldn't
tell the difference between this episode
and something that you would see in one
of the big Star Wars movies that is why
this series cost so much they spent
between 12 and 15 million dollars per
episode I believe the first character
that we meet is rands er mulk he just
calls him ran its guest star mark Boone
jr. from the Dark Knight trilogy a whole
bunch of stuff you probably recognize
him from somewhere he typically plays
pretty scummy characters it's implied
that he and the Mandalorian have all
this history together they used to run
jobs and they kind of imply through his
dialogue that the Mandalorian used to be
way more vicious using their jobs more
as target practice than to actually
earn money the whole reason for him
coming here is because he needs money so
he had to take a job and he couldn't
take one through the guild because
they're still after his head because of
baby Yoda
he seems really old here so it's hard to
tell how long ago it was that they ran
jobs together but they imply that it was
a long time ago after the mando had put
his helmet on and when I say put the
helmet on I'm talking about adopting the
culture of the Mandalorians like they
don't take their helmets off in public
for anyone like Clancy Browns Deveraux
knee and character makes jokes about the
Mandalorians if they're the most
fearsome warriors in the galaxy that how
come they're all dead but number eight
we meet bill burrs character so most of
you probably know who bill burr is if
you're not super familiar with them his
name is Mayfield in the episode he's a
former imperial sharpshooter they make a
huge joke about the original trilogy
because the Mandalorian says that's not
saying much but then bill Burke comes
back and says I wasn't a stormtrooper
haha
one of the biggest jokes about
stormtroopers from the original trilogy
is that they couldn't hit water if they
fell out of a boat he then makes a joke
about the razor crest saying that it
looks like a slot machine from Kanto
bite from the last Jedi that was the big
casino planet they went to the Deaf
Aronian is named brug obviously you
recognize him as Clancy Brown the droid
his name's zero he kind of looks like
the same type of droid his for loan from
Empire Strikes Back they were originally
protocol droids with the bug eyes he's
played by Richard I UID you probably
recognize him from the IT Crowd they
also kind of implied that he had a
relationship with the Twi'lek bounty
hunter named xi'an played by natalya
tanya from Game of Thrones in the Harry
Potter franchise her big weapon of
choices that she's really good with
throwing daggers her special daggers are
from their home planet Ryloth their
planet is noted for making really
special daggers like this they kind of
try to give each of the different bounty
hunters a special weird funny quality
like the droid keeps telling everyone
how it's smarter and better than
everyone else except for baby Yoda
which kind of makes the payoff a little
bit funnier when ninja baby Yoda totally
outsmarts the droid but number 6 WTF we
get more of the Mandalorians earlier
more vicious history they start making
fun of the Mandalorians history
wondering how good of a fighter he
really is in the twi'lek mentions as
locke 3 that planet is a super deep cut
reference for the expanding material and
some of the video games like Star Wars
Galaxies in the Old Republic
like video game it's the home planet of
the tall's aliens these furry sentient
creatures that showed up during the
original trilogy they implied that on
one of the last jobs that he ran with
these people from the black market space
station involved him leaving them behind
or some of them behind because he says
quote unquote it was the right thing to
do most of your questions about that
though get answered by the end of the
episode bill burr makes a joke about Jar
Jar Binks when he says the Mandalorian
might be a Gungan underneath his helmet
is that why you're not taking it off
they make a big thing about him taking
it off even the Deveraux nyan later in
the episode when they're fighting tries
to forcibly take it off let's see what
you look like under that helmet they
kind of imply that she anime have seen
his face underneath the helmet because
they had a sexual relationship with each
other
but number 5 the crew meets baby Yoda so
he gets into a fight with the Deveraux
knee and they accidentally find out that
little compartment the baby Yoda has
been hiding in this whole time he tries
to pass it off like a pet the droid
maneuvers them into the target zone baby
Yoda gets knocked around a lot you meant
to worry about him really up until the
end of the episode when it's him versus
the droid then you kind of get a feel
for what's really going on like oh no
he's totally fine he can take care of
himself but they really LED you along
with that baby Yoda plot through the
episode like the droids slowly finding
out what was going on with Creek cargas
message like oh no they're gonna try and
steal him at some point but they finally
make it onto the new republic ship and
there's a whole bunch of Easter eggs and
cameos in this part of the episode too
so when you first see these droids they
look just like the r1 astromech droids
from inside the Jawas sandcrawler from a
new hope only they've been upgraded so
they're floating around out instead of
wheeling around there are a bunch of
prisoners that they walk by I could only
spot a couple of them though the blue
alien that you see first is actually an
R Din Ian that's an Easter Egg for Jon
Favreau's character from solo a Star
Wars story his character was named Ryo
Durant he was the pilot of the ship
there's a random Imperial officer then
there's a small black mouse droid like
the one from a new hope on the Death
Star
these sentry droids look kind of like
downgraded smaller versions of the older
Imperial sentry droids you kind of get a
sense for things turning in the episode
things going a little bit wrong when
bill bursts character doesn't help the
Mandalorian out it's hard to tell if
he's just impressed with the Mandalorian
like oh he doesn't need our help or if
this is him just saying oh no we're
gonna double
awesome anyway so maybe he'll get killed
while he's destroying these and we won't
have to lock him up there's a really big
cameo in that New Republic guard that
they find you said it was only going to
be droids this is Matt Lanter who played
Anakin Skywalker in the Clone Wars he
did a bunch of other voices but Anakin
Skywalker was the biggest voice that he
did the uniform that he's wearing just
looks like a newer version of the rebel
fleet trooper uniforms from a new hope
at the beginning of that movie love the
way they pulled off that three-way
Mexican standoff to remember it's
supposed to be inspired by westerns and
samurai films in the three-way Mexican
standoff is a trope of western movies
most notably during the good the bad and
the ugly the homing beacon being set off
sort of gives them their ticking clock
during the episode where things really
kick into high gear in number four the
mandalorian gets thrown under the bus
when they rescue their mark the person
they're there to rescue winds up being
Quinn the very person that the
Mandalorian left behind on his big job
and as locke three that they referenced
earlier in the episode turnabout is fair
play Mandalorian as he gets thrown in
the cell and they walk off Sheehan also
makes like she always wanted to kill him
later like that was always the plan that
they were supposed to get rid of him
during the job but then back on the ship
baby Yoda gets out and starts messing
with the droid so number three baby Yoda
versus the Droid so they make like this
cat-and-mouse game where the droid can't
seem to find him like he turns around
again and he's completely gone baby Yoda
using his crazy teleporting powers again
there were a lot of mr. X and because of
what we know he's already capable of we
saw him doing things in earlier episodes
like pressing buttons and using the
force they kind of made it seem like
baby Yoda was gonna trick the droid into
getting into the Carbonite freezing area
and then he would just press the button
freezing him in carbonite when the droid
finds him in his compartment though they
actually make like he's going to use the
Force to deflect the blaster shot but
the Mandalorian shoots him from behind
before you can find out whether or not
he was actually going to do that but I
do think that he would have been able to
do it like he holds his hand up like
he's clearly getting ready to use the
Force when the Droid raises his gun
hopefully they'll pay that off in a
later episode I feel like they're
showing us him doing these things
doesn't let you know that he's capable
of them that if everything goes the way
it should you'll see them pay that off
by seeing him actually do it by the end
of the series but then
mandalorian MacGyver's his way out of
that prison cell and number two the
Mandalorians versus all the other bounty
hunters this is the part of the episode
where things turn from being more of
like a heist genre feel to more of a
horror film all the lights go red the
Mandalorian shuts down most of the areas
on the ship trying to keep them from
taking off in the Razr crest really
likes his fight with the Deveraux nyan
you learned that he's still got some
whistling birds or maybe he just picked
up all the whistling birds all that
special best guard darts from the
stormtroopers back in episode 3 he
totally eats the Mandalorians
flamethrower there were a couple
double-take twists like wait a minute
what's gonna be able to take him down he
tries to get him with the door trick
that he used against the Quarren back in
Episode one that doesn't work too
because he's so strong that he just
lifts the door up but then gets him with
a second blast shield door trick from
Return of the Jedi like oh wait there's
a second door too you find out at the
end of the episode what really happened
but they kind of imply like he killed
all those bounty hunters at first until
you find out the twist at the end no he
didn't kill them all he just locked them
up in a Cell the cinematography of his
fight with Bill burr was probably the
best but the fight itself wasn't quite
as good as the fight with the Deveraux
nyan or with the Twi'lek but he takes
them all down then takes his mark back
to the space station to collect on the
bounty the number one the big twist
ending with even more extra-special
cameos so when he takes him back to the
space station they make like ran zur
macht in the toy like are going to kill
him like here's your space craft go
after him gun and down but surprise he
put the tracker on him so the New
Republic fleet will arrive and take care
of them for the Mandalorian in the three
pilots are Dave Filoni himself
Rick family WA and Deborah Chow all
directors of the episode although Dave
flown himself is one of the co-creators
and one of the executive producers this
is also a bit of a meta Easter Egg for
Star Wars a new hope because when they
did the Death Star trench run with all
the rebel pilots at the end of episode 4
most of the actual pilots were just
people from the crew or producers George
Lucas just needed a bunch of warm bodies
so instead of picking traditional actors
he just picked people from the crew but
they actually gave them names so Dave
Leone's name is trapper wolf which I
believe is a reference to trapper one of
the clone troopers that served with mace
windu during the Clone Wars series in
the wolf part of his name is just a
reference to the loft wolf from the
our Wars rebels series did really strong
connections to the force and just like
the been do they were neither good nor
bad the loft wolves were just as really
big canonical thing as part of that
series
Rick family WA directed this episode
himself he also directed one of the
earlier episodes
his name was jib Dodger and then Deborah
Chows name was sash Keter she directed
episode three still probably the best
episode of the series so far she's also
directing episodes 7 I believe there's
no big post-credit scene or anything
like that but baby Yoda joins him in the
cockpit and he jokes to him I told you
this would be a bad idea as they slammed
the credits if he spotted any other big
easter eggs in the episode that i didn't
mention in the video just write them
below in the comments
big reminder this is a big week for Star
Wars so episode 7 the next episode will
be on Wednesday December 18th instead of
next Friday so we get it a couple days
early that's because Star Wars Episode
nine drops next Friday they didn't want
to have a big scheduling conflict but
episode 8 will be the next Friday though
so it'll go back to the regular schedule
for the finale
just in case I do get to see Star Wars
Episode nine early next week I will post
a non-spoilery review when they let us
but all my regular review and Easter Egg
videos full breakdowns will post next
weekend after everyone has a chance to
see the movie also try to do another
Mandalorian bonus video this weekend but
leave all your requests in the comments
below
congratulations Mike Mele you're the
giveaway winner from my last big man to
lorraine video please email me on the
about page of my channel so I can get
your details
everyone click here from my Mandalorian
episode 5 video and all the other
episode videos and click here for my new
baby Yoda video thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight